[Music]
and play news we do we do I wish it says
vanilla Microsoft a huge sports
employees always wanted a treehouse
because like yeah that's roughly we're
all talking about our childhood egos
remember what your mom drinks all day
and you have to cook dinner for yourself
guys talking about life yeah my dad
didn't buy what I wanted for my birthday
and your life I never got birthday
president she's like I don't even know
my birthday when I was a kid I wake up
in the garbage can every now and then my
mama did have fun fights there's no rats
in my bed you know really dude you
remember when your mama [ __ ] like
correct all your Homer I mom did TV [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
because you know too much oh yeah thank
you my friends lived in a huge like my
friends lived in a trailer park and I
would always beg my parents to move into
a trailer park because you know when
you're little you don't know like being
rich or poor yours was for adventure
dude yeah I didn't know all my friends I
loved the apartments them and all their
homies are hella tired I'm like what the
role lives upstairs
Jeremy lives over there I'm like oh my
god mom are we live in a [ __ ] house
all my friends are so [ __ ] far away
from each other I want to live an
apartment my grandma lived in an
apartment or senior assisted apartment
we used to always stay over the weekends
and we got along with all the other kids
yeah I thought I was so tight the one
thing I specifically remember we're
playing football we threw a football the
guy didn't see the tree in front of and
he knocked himself out got it - boom
amazing all right here we go
like I've never touched the football
[Music]
[ __ ] Molly I want to go here this is
my dream come true
Wow it's kind of a big [ __ ] you that you
think about it
this isn't Microsoft's why they trying
to be like we see you Microsoft they'll
come to try to make things fun that's so
that is true that is kind of morbid cuz
it's like literally hanging dead
carcasses or somebody you feel me yeah
or like no it's on fighting chicken you
dip it in the [ __ ] souls of their
basic reading them pigs pork yeah
but pigs are just cannibalism eat
anything okay [ __ ] all right I'm sorry
but it was trimming point oh wow okay
[Laughter]
it's nearly 13 feet off the ground
well the trees are crying here comes
hater Joe they're miserable when it's
raining so let's think it's a fake tree
house it's in a it's like an atrium and
[ __ ] wait a minute tree houses you get
from office to office you got to walk
that [ __ ] bridge it's just like one
space where their employees can go work
but to get to work on a windy rainy day
it is not a [ __ ] and Washington rains
a lot it does so in your Michael song oh
it'll meet the meeting space actually in
entire it's an option it's an option of
where you can go and meet it's crazy out
they have electricity right but do they
have the bucket on a string where you
can lower things down to your friend
that's a true tree how important or the
pull the slide down oh you know what
and is it wheelchair accessible [ __ ]
Google no I'm trying to you know what
I'm trying to get you guys to not make
no [ __ ] ideas because no way in hell
are we gonna spend money on making a
treehouse
don't don't even [ __ ] you to you editor
don't think and don't start protesting
Jane JK you need to make do you need to
step up your game and do a better office
so you get to have a house in your
[ __ ] office what's up with that
strike strike strike mm-hmm it's not a
tree house just the Japanese garden a
recreation of the Kyoto most comfortable
bed up everyone I know yes sometimes
like I purposely get in arguments with
Jess
so then I could get out of the house and
go into the bed you betcha he leaves
just so I could sleep on the bed
[ __ ] Muriel she goes into his office
this is awesome she you're one looks
like crap yeah I thought that was me i
sat alone what the [ __ ] I just got this
Doug she doesn't respect you huh that's
a little I don't think she knows the
ring oh yeah when people when people
snap at you for no reason just go home
well really like sassy gay oh do that do
it I'm thinking Ben's Elven dance from
Robert De Vito no the guy with the
bookie eyes the white guy I don't like
playing this guessing game he's a really
favorite community's fat or skinny I
don't like this game Tiffany okay so
ideas back to Microsoft so they that
this face is intended to help employees
benefit from what science shows nature
the powerful impact of nature on
creativity focus and happy because then
they go into a tree house with
electricity and their iPads no I thought
they'd have another streets they have a
I mean this is the problem with today
everyone's just trying to make work fun
trying to make work like outside of work
yeah no matter what you do you it's like
a shitty a shitty thing is a shitty
thing a job is a job right just because
you put a [ __ ] flower inside a piece
of [ __ ] doesn't make it not a no longer
[ __ ] it's still Dookie it's like oh come
do your work
cuz it's cool here there's trees here
right but the work still [ __ ] sucks
all I'm saying is work is work
get your [ __ ] done and then go have a
vacation don't be trying to have a
vacation at work it's all fake terrible
picture have you ever seen it Michael
plays every day
Michael's Chinese true no so you don't
believe in the fact that like the
employees could be more creative and I
used to and then I made JK really fun
and in nobody's working anymore I would
just keep playing and I'm angry so I
want to go back to the days when we used
to work the shop ya know this but Joe's
the one editing he's here wearing all
masks none of us are in any other videos
it's just him busting of all the roles
Tyler Perry Charlie
everyone's busy going on vacations
playing ping pong playing that [ __ ]
barbel basketball game and now we're
making the office even more fun because
there's more ways to sleep now we got
sleeping bags we got freaking stepping
yeah working from home why do you think
no but you're not Joe this [ __ ]
telling you the articles in your ear cuz
he does all the work we bring back my
favorite feed bag please
it was mine yeah it was rain got to
admit smells mostly girls yeah do you
guys ever throw it away I don't know I
think we did the point is is that it was
used and that's all that matters Nadeem
gloves on it cuz lightweight I wish I
would have got that bean bag instead
because I got the smaller version I
thought when I saw how dope it was what
is that BAE yeah I [ __ ] up I'm not
gonna buy two bean bags
here's what I propose all right we build
robots to do the farming for us to do
all the construction for us
all that stuff but make them just a
little bit stupid though so they can't
take over us and then we just we don't
work no no need to escape work or
anything else just have no obligations
we have to work for money we work for
play so if you want to achieve like I
want to be the fastest guy in the world
you could focus on that you don't have
to work at McDonald's while you like try
to make it to college but then they'll
be out of job what's happening I want
money to spend
we don't need money I'm sorry Toby in
world so I could throw Duke yet people
see but you're too busy doing whatever
you're doing that you can't do that
right now it's true see you're so funny
you just changed your own argument you
started off saying we need to work more
and not have so much fun and now I hear
you're realize that was stupid hey guys
I hope you guys enjoy the video please
remember to give us a big thumbs up and
a like like like and also when you guys
sign on YouTube make sure just kidding
news are the first thing you watch every
single day because we post videos every
day ok for more videos